hey we good t
never better amigo
good
franklin now he'll be here
franklin all right what's up
i assume you got him oh safe and sound
ain't that right buddy
my bad homie i picked c ain't that a
[ __ ]
you know devin the way i see it and hey
i'm no intelligent businessman like you
but the way i see it there's two great
evils that bedevil american capitalism
the type that you practice number one
is outsourcing you paid a private
company to do your dirty work for you
and then you underpaid that company
because you thought you were big enough
and bad enough that you didn't have to
play by the rules oh number two
offshoring your profits
offshoring oh it's horrible you wouldn't
want to be sent offshore just to save a
little money would you t no i i wouldn't
oh no
nowhere no see but we know your opinions
on the matter devon keep your problems
the [ __ ] out of america huh
in this instance when he puts it like
that it makes sense of course it does
hey devon
goodbye my old friend thanks for all the
advice
so now what
now we keep a low profile and get on
with our lives
as friends
well do i have a choice no not really
all right then
as uh flawed awful totally uncomfortable
and poorly matched friends absolutely oh
that's perfect then we can get back to
the kind of capitalism we practice [ __ ]
i don't know how much more better that
is than devin's con ooh hypocrisy
franklin civilization's greatest virtue
jesus your therapist has a lot to answer
for i know i still hate myself
but hey at least i know the words for it
now yeah but i hate you and i know the
words for it so does that mean i don't
have to go to therapy look man
you two [ __ ] terrified me of
that middle age i'm good you're right to
be afraid franklin yeah be very afraid
franklin
stay at one thing t
i'm getting too old for this nonsense
is
we got the